that is a reported infatuation of team
owner jerry jones stephen
during that appearance on 105 3 the fan
in dallas asked about his father's
infatuation with kyle pitts here's the
answer
uh given his view on uh you know what a
unique football player kyle pitts is
he's a unique match-up player and
certainly
if you look at the chiefs and the 49ers
and
the way new england utilized them over
the years these mismatched tight end
players can certainly
make a big difference in offensive
football and i think
you'd be hard-pressed i think to find
anyone who knows football
personnel wise in the nfl
coaches that can't see a vision for what
uh you know the the problems a player
like kyle pitts
could present i think he's a unique
player that doesn't come around every
year and certainly jerry was just
acknowledging that
and and look i
no one is going to tell us exactly what
they're planning to do or whether it was
i my first reaction was somebody in the
organization who doesn't want jerry to
take kyle pitts or trade up to take kyle
pitts he's leaking that out there so
kyle pitts isn't available for them to
take because they have other needs the
last thing they need is a pass catcher
when you've got amari cooper michael
gallup and cd lamb but regardless pitts
is a special player
and and there's a chance there's a
chance he'll be there at 10. there's a
chance he could be in striking distance
if they want to jump up to get him but
uh you know the cowboys as we mentioned
they've got plenty of needs
they have some some very good players
but to be the team that they
continuously are hyped to be you're in
and you're out they've got some work
that needs to be done and that's why i
don't rule out a trade down
really i i'm i'm a very big believer if
you're a team that's got multiple needs
i say stockpile lottery tickets because
they're every one of those tickets if
you trust your board every one of those
tickets can end up being a good player
and uh the more good players obviously
no matter how how many holes you have
the more good players you come out of
any draft with the better off you're
gonna be sharing
yeah mike i don't profess to be an
expert at the draft i watch college
football but i don't study it like these
experts do but everyone keeps telling me
that the 2022 and 2023 drafts are going
to be way better than this draft so why
not
if you do have multiple needs you have a
coach a young coach who you think is
going to be there a while young
quarterback who's going to be there a
while why not move down and stockpile
those picks you still could come out of
this draft with two defensive starters
and multiple picks 2022 2023 and i just
think that would be a great move for him
unless there's a guy you're dying to
take the cowboys unlike many teams do
not hide their intentions for years
the players they brought in on those 30
visits that they got in past years they
were going to take a player out of that
group that they brought in morris
claiborne was the only guy that they
didn't bring in that they ended up
drafting that was only because they
traded up to get him and obviously they
should not have drafted him where they
did i think he was a six overall pick
that year but they never try to hide
their intentions and and jerry jones had
talked a lot about his love for johnny
manziel before that draft he wanted to
draft johnny manziel he said that he
wanted to draft johnny manziel and they
talked him out of that so
it will be interesting to me and i would
love to see if kyle pitts is on the
board when the cowboys draft if jerry
gets his way and drafts kyle pitts or if
they talk him out of that trade down do
something else drafted defensive player
whatever they end up doing kyle pitts
could go on and be an an all-pro great
tight end that everybody says he thinks
he's going to be but
how many targets is he going to get in
dallas you just used the first round
pick on cd lamb last year that would
probably mean at that point you're
trading one of those receivers more
likely michael gallup who's in the last
year of his rookie deal just because of
his contract but you're probably trading
hib is what you're ending up doing if
you get caught pits mike
i don't think mark cooper is going to be
around after this year either that's
another factor in that you're right
claiborne was the sixth overall pick
back in 2012. i remember jerry being
smitten with darren mcfadden in 2008 he
had never drafted anyone from arkansas
during his time as owner of the team
went with felix jones darren mcfadden's
backfield teammate in arkansas in round
one that year because they weren't
nearly high enough to get darren
mcfadden who was the fourth overall pick
of the raiders what do they do you
mentioned manziel in 2014 what do they
do to talk him out of it because at the
end of the day
if he wants to call rank
he's holding the pink slip on the
franchise i want johnny manziel i'm
taking johnny manzo what do they do to
talk him off the ledge
well that was really the first year mike
that he started listening to his scouts
right they had been so bad at drafting
and he listened and he said what about
johnny manziel and it was crickets in
the room at that point according to what
a scout told me nobody said anything
about johnny manziel and then they all
of a sudden start talking about zach
martin which obviously has been the best
pick that they could have made at that
point the guy's on his way to a hall of
fame career if he can stay healthy a
couple more years so that was the pick
to make at that point but that was the
point i think mike that he really
started listening to stephen jones and
to all those scouts in the room and not
trying to do it on his own figuring out
that all right they know better than me
they study this stuff year round i'm
just here to to lend an ear to what they
have to say
it just occurred to me after all these
years that maybe it was an extra-large
tumbler of johnny walker blue
that got
jerry jones to forget about johnny
manziel that
may have been the answer and they may
need more johnny walker blue to get him
to forget about kyle pitts on draft
night just nine days away
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports